welcome to another ideas that matters
conversation I have here uh from across
the world at least across the Atlantic
David feidler the author of the recent
book breakfast with Seneca stoic art to
the guide of living and this is our
first chance to actually sit down and
have a full chat he's also the editor of
the living ideas journal and we're going
to put links to all of these things
below you might check out the article
how philosophy changed the world which
is going to be what we're going to be
talking about today how stoic philosophy
is not just something in ancient Greece
and Rome or the Mediterranean in general
but also leads to the birth of the
Renaissance and how it could be useful
today there's a lot of ground that we're
going to cover I think David can also
tell you about this interesting course
that he has coming up as well we're
gonna probably touch on what happens
when you teach people in beautiful
environments
um so it should be an interesting
conversation and the the main topic that
were ostensibly grappling with is this
one about stoicism is not just something
that happened as a lot of people think
in ancient times and then had a
Resurgence in let's call it late modern
times the you know the last maybe 30 40
years going back in Academia maybe 60
years but there was a really important
thing that happened in between that I
guess you could say made it possible for
it to have a Resurgence in our presence
and so what is that
well uh it's really interesting because
I've been interested in the Renaissance
my entire life I started off studying
like uh
platonism and neoplatonism so I studied
uh the influence of Plato in the
Renaissance which comes in like the very
late 1400s but recently I started
studying the origins of the Renaissance
and I really discovered some shocking
things because if you go back
and look at it uh you discovered that it
was actually stoic philosophy that was
the Prime uh inspiration uh behind
Renaissance humanism which was like the
the source of the entire Renaissance
and when people think of the Renaissance
uh I mean understandably they usually
think about art yeah but in you know so
that's that's like the typical response
but in reality
um the Renaissance itself was a uh
desire to uh revive the ancient Roman
and Greek worlds and their culture and
their deepest values and uh of course
that did profoundly influence the art
but they were trying to recover the
philosophy and all of the knowledge from
the ancient world and in this discussion
we can get into why they actually wanted
to do that because they had a pretty
compelling reason for that but um
it's actually somewhat shocking if
you're interested in in stoicism to
discover that stoicism inspired the
earliest Renaissance humanists to create
the Renaissance and that's something
that you know like a small circle of
Scholars they know about it but it's not
really uh generally known I think it's
also
um very interesting for us today if
we're people interested in stoicism
because
there's sort of like this underlying
maybe even you could call it a crisis in
modern stoicism because we all know that
you can use stoic philosophy to improve
your own life but then there's like this
big question is you know could it really
contribute to society in some way and I
think that this whole process of how
stoicism influenced the early
Renaissance humanists is very applicable
today it's sort of like a case history
of what could be done with stoicism
because in my view the Renaissance was
really the largest cultural
transformation in the history of the
western world and if stoicism
contributed to that in a deep way which
it did it raises the question of uh
would that be possible today and how
I mean that's a really interesting
set of ideas and I think some of the
distinctions that that somebody might
make or bring because I think if I
understand you right your claim is
actually a very strong one you know
somebody could say well you know the
stoics they they influence the beginning
of the Renaissance but then there's not
that much substantive engagement going
on after that so it's kind of a
precursor or some you know so a catalyst
but you're saying no no it's uh it's
there at the beginning which I I buy I
mean they had Seneca we uh we know that
they had a boulderized version of
Epictetus and that you know as these
Scholars are coming West fleeing the uh
the decaying and eventually to fall
Byzantine Empire they're bringing texts
with them so I I mean I'm I'm I buy that
I think a lot of people problems you
know though because they're this is not
how it's taught at all right when when
we get it in World Civ or even
Humanities class classes it is usually
presented as if it's well it's it's uh a
bold new adventure and people are
creating new philosophies and there's
not a lot of talk about
um the platonism involves Doses and
Revival of epicureanism so I'm I'm
actually curious to learn
about I mean I know in the early modern
period the stoicism that is running
throughout all these these people but to
hear that it's a substantive
contribution to the development not just
a philosophy but but human thought right
and understanding say how to move
forward socially
um into as technology is progressing and
and you know uh all sorts of religious
conflicts are Brewing
um that that strikes me as a very
interesting and strong claim so I look
forward to hearing about that and I
don't I have to admit I don't know much
about Renaissance philosophy I had uh
you know we didn't get any of that and I
think this is the case in most places in
our historical sequence and I was
fortunate enough to have an interest in
Johann wazinga and also to have a
colleague who specialized in Renaissance
philosophy who retired and put all of
his books out in the hall at one point
and so I snatched them up and and read
through them and it was quite it was
quite eye-opening you know to see who
was doing what and reinterpreting what
but I can't claim to any expertise or
having even read those books in probably
a decade so right well I specialize in
researching things they don't teach you
in school
yeah and this is definitely one of them
but uh sort of like one of uh the
interesting ideas sort of like this
little sub-argument that I make is
actually stoicism in the ancient world
it was very influential in terms of
impacting the lives of individuals and
helping them to live you know better and
happier lives but I really don't think
that stoicism had much impact on society
in the ancient world it was mainly an
individual thing because like the social
conditions were different
so that's an interesting one right there
and I think to go back to like you
talked about these I forget the word you
used crisis perhaps in the stoic
Community
um I mean I think there's also there's a
second crisis in the stoic community
um where we've got I I just call it like
something along the lines of
well-researched stoicism actual stoicism
a commitment to the to studying the
classic stock text and applying them and
then all of these weird
pseudostoicisms I I usually call it fake
stoicism but I should I should switch to
pseudostosism where you know it's all
about
um being a tough guy or you know
maximizing your productivity or these
these weird things that people do that
turn it into life hacks and the you know
there's this big line out there that
well the Roman Empire was great because
it was stoic you know and and you know
that's that's not the case at all right
that's what you're saying well
indisputable that these stoics had an
incredibly pro-social philosophy right
that historically would be incredibly
influential but it's just that in that
particular time in the Roman Empire they
didn't really have much of an
opportunity to exercise that and so the
thing that I find interesting is that
if you compare
how stoicism actually helps spark the
Renaissance with this huge cultural
transformation it was like a different
time and place so circumstances were
different and
you know that's an interesting aspect
about stoicism is that there were a lot
of uh sort of like seed or seminal ideas
and stoicism that weren't really
realized in the ancient world that were
later you're making a pun there so you
should you should stop for a second
let's say why it's actually a pun
because I think some of the people
listening might not get that oh well
seed and seminal I mean uh and there's I
mean I I don't know how deep the pun
goes actually
the spermatic reasons is that what
exactly yeah yeah
I mean it plays a role in a lot of
people's thinking you know one of the
things with stoicism as well as
aristotelianism is
neoplatonism would kind of suck those
things in and use whatever worked and
the seminal reasons you know whatever
those those happen to be there's a lot
of scholarly debate about just what they
are I mean we see it we see Augustine
invoking these and a lot of early other
early Christian thinkers who are
influenced by both platonism and
anstosism invoking it so I thought that
that was you know a subtle uh joke that
you were you were making but it's a
great opportunity
[Laughter]
but I shouldn't have interrupted you so
uh these these seminal reasons operating
within ancient Society but
um you know Cicero who was not exactly a
stoic but he was very happy heavily
influenced by stoic philosophy he also
influenced the Renaissance very deeply
and we'll talk about that as we we go on
but he had a very very strong and he
developed these ideas actually from
stoic ideas but he had a a very very
strong idea of what we might call civic
virtue and that became incredibly
important in the Renaissance and it's
all about how philosophy can contribute
to society so that was articulated much
more deeply than the stoics did even
though the stoics were incredibly you
know pro-social as you can see in the
stoic writings
right so how do we get
um you're talking about the early
Renaissance or the beginnings of the
Renaissance so I think a lot of people
are very hazy they know that there's you
know an ancient period a medieval period
then this thing the Renaissance and the
Reformation supposed to happen kind of a
little bit after it and you know maybe
they they bleed together or something so
when when do we actually say the
Renaissance
began and who does it begin with okay so
you know that's somewhat debatable but
what I would say is that the Renaissance
really started to emerge
in full form like around the year 1400
in Florence but before that is where is
when all of the foundational ideas were
laid by
um this Italian scholar Francesco
petrarca who's normally called Petra
Petra yeah yeah and so he was in the
1300s and so he's he's like one of the
two Renaissance characters I'll talk
about in this discussion but
he's incredibly fascinating uh he was
interested in so many things but
basically he was a classical scholar he
was born in 1304 and lived until 1374.
uh he was a classical scholar he studied
law which he hated he was a law school
dropout like many humanists who would
follow in his footsteps he lived through
the plague or the black death which
killed 60 of the population
and he was the founder of Renaissance
humanism and what that really means is
that in his work and his life he really
developed all the ideas that guided
Renaissance humanism and he had a lot of
followers in fact
um he was really well connected with
people he was sort of like a poet
Ambassador he was he worked as an
ambassador for the church and he had
these correspondents all across Europe
and he actually even published 550 of
his letters
in addition to his books so
um he described himself as someone who
was addicted to writing and so we know
exactly what he thought because all of
his writings have
um
come down to us but he studied these uh
you know ancient Latin classical
writings they didn't they weren't able
to read Greek at the time and he was
like really the bridge between the
Middle Ages and the Renaissance
and what he firmly believed through his
study of these ancient classical
writings is that
there were better times in the past
in the Roman Empire and that he was
actually living in a period of cultural
collapse that began with the fall of the
Roman Empire and he saw the earlier
Roman civilization as being morally and
culturally superior to the time in
which he lived and there are these
themes that run through all of his
writings and I'll just I'll just mention
like four or five of them okay uh one of
them is that Italy was no longer a
unified land like it was in Roman times
it was a collection of Warring
city-states many of which were ruled by
tyrants and it was also very dangerous
to travel there so it was like the
peasants in the countryside were armed
so when he traveled to Rome he had to do
so like under uh armed guard
um another thing that was really
significant to petrarch and the later
humanists is they came to realize that
over the thousand years since the fall
of Rome that the Latin language had
become very corrupt
and in patriarch size and the eyes of
the humanists
um it was very corrupt compared to the
beautiful Latin Style of Cicero which
they tried to uh recover he felt the
legal system had become corrupt uh he
studied that in school
um he said that it sold Justice and he
was also a very devout Catholic and he
felt that the church had become
incredibly corrupt and uh in his
lifetime uh the papacy actually was no
longer located in Rome it was in
southern France where he and his family
moved and his dad worked for the papacy
as a kind of you know writer or Diplomat
and so petrarch himself had a lot of
firsthand knowledge about the inner
workings of the church and he referred
to it as the Western Babylon and anesta
fornicators
so he felt that there was some room for
improvement there yeah that's an
understatement yeah and finally
um there's a fifth point to which he
felt that philosophy had become corrupt
through the medieval scholasticism of
his day uh which became like a very
highly codified kind of philosophy based
on the ideas of Aristotle so that was
like the official academic world of his
day and he wasn't he wasn't uh
anti-aristotle per se but uh
scholasticism as a movement had become
sort of a cult-like intellectual
movement that focused on very shallow
you know stifling logical arguments and
at the same time it's like these
Scholastic philosophers they never
thought about like what does it really
mean to be human and what is important
for human beings to lead a good life it
became very disconnected and
intellectual so in in a real sense
humanism was a reaction against that and
it was an attempt to rehumanize
philosophy and the world
yeah I mean you think back to
um
somebody like abelard right and and you
can see he's essentially you know one of
the earliest persons who's a real
Scholastic sometimes they say Anselm's
father scholasticism but that that's
clearly not right because he's teaching
in Cathedral and monastic uh circles and
he doesn't he doesn't actually proceed
the you know with the pros and cons and
stuff like that and that's sterility
right
um I've always been struck by that as as
early as as abelard and then you know
you look at
um now Aquinas on the other hand you
know vast scope isn't just Aristotle
he's bringing in to masking and
chrysostom and Augustine and all these
other interesting people and and you you
look at that and you're like well
scholasticism doesn't look too bad then
but that was sort of like it'd be like
judging a whole crowd of people by just
the one interesting person that you run
across at a conference for example you
you wander into a conference for I I
don't know like
something on Shale and you don't know
anything about Shale but there's one guy
who's who's fun to chat with
um that's not the whole conference right
and and I'm struck as well and this I
understand there's a little bit of
rambling
you know when you read Descartes and his
account of his own education so granted
he's coming you know quite a bit later
um that Devotion to Aristotle as having
having like figured everything out
having everything right it almost sounds
like atla flesh there was almost
something analogous to fundamentalism
but of Aristotle's works so that right
well the answer must be in there
somewhere we just need to find the right
passage rather than actually you know
looking at the world or thinking about
golf or yeah exactly it's I mean
Aristotle uh
wasn't I mean he certainly wasn't bad
but yeah it's just the way that they
used his works and started thinking
about it in a really dogmatic way as if
you know he had all of the answers so it
tended so whenever you take that
approach with any kind of philosophy it
tends to shut down you know like
independent thinking and human inquiry
and all of that but um
what happened with Patrick this is a
really key idea is that based on his
study of ancient literature he decided
that there had been this really
Monumental collapse of civilization and
he actually invented the idea of the
Dark Ages
and he believed that he was living in
the Dark Ages maybe if he was lucky he
was living at the end of the Dark Ages
it's interesting isn't it because we
usually construe it as okay that's after
the collapse of Rome and all this
Barbarian stuff going on and don't have
a lot of records and then Irish monks
keeping Greek alive you know all these
funny stories that we tell but we
usually say well that that came to an
end with the high Middle Ages you know
and suddenly everything if we're in a
movie turns from the the dark filter to
you know maybe like nights with their
pet Penance and stuff like that joustic
with each other
and uh I mean from what you're saying so
petrarch is like nope that's Dark Ages
too you know the whole damn thing is
Dark Ages all the way up to right now
well
um some people find this to be a highly
controversial idea
in a historical sense but actually that
doesn't matter in terms of our
discussion because this is what they
believed exactly and this is what
catalyzed their action and so what
petrarch believed is that you know there
was this period of the Dark Ages which I
I personally think it's somewhat
credible but aside from that what he
really believed is that his time had
become so corrupt that the only way that
they could create a better world was to
revive the knowledge and philosophy of
the ancient world to create like a more
virtuous world and to create you know
more virtuous leaders because there was
all this incredible corruption and so
it's this idea of of the Dark Ages and
we're going to revive the light of the
ancient world that marks the beginning
of the Renaissance it's it's a rebirth
of the classical world and its values so
he was inspired by ancient philosophy
and
in the 1300s no one could read Creek so
who represented ancient philosophy uh I
mean aside from Aristotle which actually
existed in like pretty bad uh
translations uh
who represented ancient Philosophy for
the early humanists was Seneca and
Cicero
and uh because they had all those Latin
texts they actually discovered more
works of Cicero in the Renaissance
because they became obsessed with
discovering lost manuscripts and uh
monasteries in fact even petrarch
discovered like the Lost letters of
Cicero but uh Cicero you know taught
this idea of civic virtue or how
philosophy could create a a better
Society because he was both a
philosopher and a Statesman and this
idea became incredibly influential in
the Renaissance so they wanted to create
people like this who were like learned
philosophers and could also make
significant contributions to society
politically so this was like an
archetype for them
and they actually it's interesting can
we pause on that first yes because a lot
of times people will bring up you know
Plato's philosopher king and then
they'll point out and say Marcus
Aurelius and oh where else do we find
these but it's almost like you don't
want somebody who's going to be a
philosopher and then catapults
themselves to the very highest level and
is monarchical or you know the flip side
tyrannical you you need all these other
people in between who are willing to not
try to you know
get to the top but are but are
interested in performing their role
really well and making sure that what
they're doing doesn't conflict with the
the guy next door who's in charge of the
sewers or something like that all the
all the things that are less you know
sexy and and uh Prestige driven but are
what makes a society work and so you
know the stoics they have this very
heavy emphasis on role ethics does that
figure into that
um
being willing to take you know right not
the highest position but something that
that actually kind of kind of makes
sense I mean you could also liken it to
the cursive sonorum that people like
Cicero right themselves did you know you
don't become
um console right away you gotta first
you gotta like put on the games and make
sure that people are being uh censured
properly and run the sewers and things
like like that yeah well what I would
say is that the the ideas of humanism
had impact on every aspect of society
and one of the reasons that they were so
attracted to Cicero in Florence is that
Florence wasn't actually it was a
republic with some type of democratic
representation like the Republic of uh
you know Cicero's Rome so they felt this
incredible you know resonance with with
sister on this idea of making a
contribution to um
Society now whether they were really
interested in role ethics or not I don't
know because a lot of the humanists were
obsessed with Fame
[Laughter]
including Petro he was he was totally
obsessed with Fame and he did become
actually the most famous intellectual
and all of Europe so at least he was
successful at it yeah yeah
you know if not at the top of the
political pile at the top of the
intellectual literary pile yeah I think
Cicero had written a work on
um the desirability of Fame as well that
was lost but but uh anyways they wanted
to create a better society and so what
happened is they created this program of
studies called the studio humanitarus
which we would call the humanities they
created the humanities really or Humane
studies yeah
and that consisted of five different
branches that consisted of grammar
which was really the study of Latin and
uh rhetoric persuasive speaking poetry
history and moral philosophy but the
ultimate study was moral philosophy or
how to develop a better character you
know or a better society as well and all
the other branches of
you know the humanities were to support
this like so you would read poetry to
become a better person and you would
read history to read about you know like
role models
and
I'll go ahead yes no no go ahead well I
was wondering I mean because the
universities already had their own
structure with you know the Seven
Liberal Arts and then philosophy is is
the juncture point of it but it's not
just moral philosophy it's what we do
nowadays call moral philosophy plus
epistemology and metaphysics and maybe a
few other things as well but but it was
always none of those were supposed to be
the end point they were all supposed to
lead to you know law or medicine or
theology right right exactly um this was
this new course which is very
interesting because it it's much less
focused on the what was you know called
the mathematical Arts which some of them
like of course arithmetic and geometry
but music was in there and and astronomy
and we don't usually think of those as
particularly mathematical but they were
part of that it seems like that that the
new course is de-emphasizing that and
sort of Plumping out the the Trivium by
adding the things that used to be in
grammar so when you would study grammar
you would you would read literature as
models but now now looking at it as our
history as well those things as being
worthwhile studying in their own right
to develop you fully as a human being
not just as a path to ultimately do
theology or lar medicine so I guess what
I'm asking are two things one was was
this intended to like
supplement or replace what a university
education up to philosophy was supposed
to if he was a viewed as a rival to that
and then
um second you know how are these this is
a broader question how are these
subjects supposed to humanize you as
you're saying make you a fully developed
human being right well those are really
good questions and
um
so part I think part of the studio
humanitaris it was a pushback against
the kind of medieval curriculum because
you're absolutely correct if you went to
a university the three endpoints were to
study law
um
medicine or theology
and so by inventing this studio
humanitaris they were creating this
other option and uh initially it was an
educational system that existed outside
of universities and then eventually you
know over the decades it was
assimilated but they were pushing back I
think against the medieval curriculum
because what they really did was uh
they took the study of logic out and
replaced it with rhetoric
because the idea was that if you're
going to contribute to society you have
to be able to speak in a persuasive way
and that was very important for example
to petrar because there's this very
famous passage where he's talking about
studying uh Aristotle's nicomaki and
ethics
and what he says is that yes I can learn
things about virtue from Aristotle but
the problem is is that he's essentially
offering definitions of Virtues and he's
not telling me how to become a better
person which actually is something that
Massimo palucci said about the nikomaki
in ethics too which I really thought
because he sort of like reinvented some
of these humanistic ideas on his own
through his own reading just
spontaneously and uh so there was this
attempt to you know broaden the types of
studies and this whole idea of the
studio humanitas it really goes back to
Cicero because he had this
um idea of humanitas which was like a
virtue for him which meant becoming uh a
fully realized human being and you know
very deeply human and that's achieved
through the study of like Humane letters
and history but the way that all of the
way that the humanists looked at it is
that these studies like poetry
uh and literature if you approach them
in the right way they would help people
to become more virtuous because they
would like raise the human spirit and
offer inspiring examples of you know
what what it is to be human so that was
like the the original goal but the thing
that I find to be incredibly shocking is
that
uh I mean all of this is historically
established but if you were to go into a
Humanities Department today
99.9 of the humanities professors would
have no idea that the original purpose
of the humanities was to create better
people
yeah it's funny if you think about what
an average Humanities class looks like
in a lot of places it's like just a
Virago of all sorts of things thrown in
together and they don't begin with the
Renaissance or or even with Cicero
they're probably even not going to
mention Cicero except they'll have like
a little bust in the textbook and
they'll say yeah this guy was a Roman he
wrote some books they'll they'll you
know first start talking about the
pyramids and you know about cave
paintings and and things like that
that's that's great I mean
no no need to disparage all these
wonderful things that human beings have
created but it's not it's not properly
speaking in the humanities unless you're
like retroactively reading everything
backwards in there and you know my and
my limited experience with seeing people
taking and teaching Humanities classes
they come out and you can't even say
that they have like a thin veneer
because a veneer would have some
continuity right there would be there
would be something there that holds it
all together they just know that like
this thing happened at this time and
this person did a painting and this
person did a song and that there were
movements but they they don't get any
sense of
something that has coherence and they
they don't they certainly don't get the
history of it that way which is a very
You Know Rich complex deep history
they're not even getting like a little
sliver of it right they're not there's
no overall
coherent sense of what Humanities would
actually be exactly and I think that
it's quite plausible that that's why the
humanities are in such a serious state
of collapse now I mean you've
undoubtedly read all the statistics and
you're familiar with that but
um it seems that and part of that may
actually be justified because people
today no longer understand what the
actual value of the humanities is and in
the past they did have a common AIM now
maybe we shouldn't go back exactly to
the humanities of the past but the idea
of having a common aim to create
you know better people right who are
able to create a better society that
would add incredible value to the
humanities so you know I I mean I I see
a motif when there's meetings about this
guy I actually work in a department of
uh Humanities and liberal arts you know
uh which is you know there's an
interesting question about how those
those parse out and there's a lot of
aspirational language that gets used in
these meetings and sometimes even in
documents but it remains at such an
abstract level so they'll talk about say
fostering critical thinking and that's a
super equivocal term and everybody lays
claim to teaching critical thinking in
some way or another and most of the
claims are actually bogus because you
can you can say well what do you mean by
critical thinking is it this model is it
this model at least there are some you
know models out there the Paul L yeah
Paul Elder and and uh you know like the
APA I think it's the gold standard
Delphi report on on critical thinking
and you can say okay are you are you
doing any of these things or how how
much are you doing them but I think in
you know and here I'm just throwing out
a number because we don't really know
probably 90 percent of the humanities
departments that are claiming that in
their classes they're fostering critical
thinking or we could pick any other like
big skill like you know written
communication they're probably not doing
that you know they're probably and it's
almost you could say is it worse to say
that you're doing it because now you
think that you're doing it and you don't
actually have to like look at your
practices or is it better just not even
to to not do it but not claim to to do
it at least then you're aware of the
deficits and
it would take an awful lot in
contemporary colleges and universities
to
produce a curriculum that really does
Foster Pick It Whatever skill you want
in this case you know but I just took
critical thinking as one example
um in in a coherent way where you can
show that there's development from the
person coming in as a young student a
freshman to being ready to graduate you
know
[Music]
um
that's that's a bit of a rant I'm
actually like recalling uh the uh you
may remember arum and I forget who his
collaborator was uh academically adrift
that was uh published back in the
early
OTS you know
um and what it is it took actual
critical thinking scores that you can
measure with a pretty decent tool called
the Collegiate learning assessment
um which requires you to do these
performance tasks and and all of that
and uh you can see that in most uh
American schools students were coming in
and leaving at exactly the same level
four years later you know I this is
again going off on a tangent but you may
have had this experience as well we
teach things in classes and then we see
our students you know two three
semesters later and they've forgotten
almost everything and I always tell them
wow you really wasted a lot of money uh
you know to take a class at Marquette
University if you're averaging out what
tuition is it's like five thousand
dollars so you sat your butt in a seat
and you couldn't remember anything uh
after the class was over because you you
memorized what you needed to do to pass
the test kind of like in Scholastic
times we could say
although the tests are very different
then and then it all just kind of drops
out and I think part of the reason it
does that is because there's no net
there's no Nexus or Matrix to keep all
of these important
text thinkers ideas caught within you
know yeah well I just have to also
digress tell you a really funny story or
actually yeah yeah because when I first
became a philosophy professor in
Michigan when I lived there I was
assigned a mentor in the department oh
wow and I taught uh my in my intro to
philosophy course I was trying to teach
the students what an argument was okay
and so one of the assignments that I
gave the students which was a fabulous
assignment they did a fantastic job on
it as I said what you have to do is just
construct an argument with uh premises
reasoning and a conclusion
and of course for a beginning college
student they've never even heard of that
really right yeah so that was a very
good assignment and I said you can do uh
you can create an argument about
whatever you want you know any topic but
it just has to follow the pattern of
having premises reasoning and a
conclusion and they picked all these
different topics and they did a really
incredible job and then I had them read
them out out loud in class it was
wonderful and then um my my mentor
my faculty Mentor I walked into his
office one day and he said to me he said
you know David
I've been teaching uh Philosophy for
several decades and there's one thing
that you should never do
you should never ask students to think
for themselves
this
and I was so shocked my jaw hit the
floor yeah but the reason the reason he
said that actually is that he was a
calvinist
and so in his belief system you
shouldn't really ask people to think for
themselves you should ask them to come
and see the world in the correct way
yeah well you know it was shocking
though I was to to hear a philosophy
Professor say you should never ask
students to think for themselves I mean
obviously that should be the ungold
philosophies that people can think for
themselves yeah it's sort of settling
for the second class right because I
mean there's Aristotle and other
philosophers will sometimes say this
including Descartes interestingly about
doubt that
um you know thinking for yourself
awesome that's the best thing to do
figure it out you know do all the things
that we we often praise if you don't
know the mental faculties to do that
then you're better off following
somebody who won't steer you wrong right
and so this guy that you're talking
about is saying ah
none of us are ready for for that which
makes sense for McAlister's perspective
as a certain kind of calvinist
perspective there's there's a you know a
denigration of the rational faculties
that goes on and and so the best is just
to find something that we can isn't
going to steer us wrong and we won't be
too troubled by thinking oh this doesn't
make any sense yeah yeah
I once uh delivered a paper there to the
faculty colloquia man this guy he like
wrote All Over the paper and he said
where did you get these ideas where did
you get these ideas and I said well
actually I worked them out myself and he
was like shocked by that oh he thought
that interesting he thought that I had
to derive them from some other source
but I actually you know did it with my
own reasoning but anyways
right it is possible yes it's it's
possible I mean think how much better
the world would be if people could
engage in their own critical thinking
but yeah there's there's one one extra
thing that I'd like to talk about though
is just talk about really How Deeply
these people were influenced by stoicism
just to document it so yeah this is like
not an idle claim that I'm making and uh
there's this uh Israeli scholar uh
gurzak hopefully I pronounce that
correctly uh who wrote this fantastic
article called humanism as a way of life
uh Leon Batista Alberti and the legacy
of petrarch and um if you read this
article and you know about stoic
practices the article is basically just
an exposition of all the story practices
and ideas that you find in the works
interesting so yeah that's unbelievable
so they're not just incorporating
key ideas coming from stoicism or maybe
kicking them around could there be an
you know actorosis or not or things like
that they're actually taking
the practices out of the stoic text and
saying let's try this out and see how it
works because that I mean that's a very
interesting bridge to you know what we
call the modern stoic movement exactly
no it's just the same they know they
were doing the story practices it's
unbelievable and uh he summarizes them
in this article I can send you a copy of
it worth taking a look at yeah yeah but
uh that shows you how deeply they were
were interested and
um so we've talked a bit about petric
but I'd like to mention uh Leon Batista
Alberti who's my favorite humanist and
he was born exactly 100 years after
petrex so that would have been 1404 when
the Renaissance was really starting to
take off in Florence and he was one of
the greatest minds of the Renaissance he
was like an architect he was an art
theorist he introduced the study of
mathematics and science to humanism
and what people have really failed to
realize is that he was actually a stoic
philosopher because he wrote a lot about
ethics and you can see this very clearly
in his work
um he wrote this incredible dialogue
called on the Tranquility of the Soul
which has not yet been translated into
English it's been translated into German
which I just recently read and on the
Tranquility of the soul is actually the
title of an essay by Seneca right right
yeah yeah and so this
a dialogue that he wrote it's basically
a textbook of Seneca stoicism with
hundreds of references to Seneca and
paraphrases of Seneca
and he wrote another book called on the
Family
uh which is like practical ethics and
that has uh quite a few stoic passages
in it as well and he wrote an anonymous
uh autobiography in which he actually
explains his use of stoic exercises you
know things like we would call today
like exposure therapy so if you take his
writings as a whole together you could
see him I mean it's it's really
unavoidable if you know about stoicism
and you read his stuff it's it's
impossible not to see him it's an
interesting point right there's a lot of
cases where we're now recognizing or or
at least some people recognize before
that this person is drawing on stoic
ideas because but they didn't mention
the word stoic in there and so and
they're often not all that well read so
you know for example much later Marge
Cavendish is you know discussing
causality and she's talking about things
in in stoic ways but a lot of her
readers at the time might have
recognized it but then she kind of Fades
Into Obscurity and a lot of uh academics
aren't you know checking it out until
till recently and then you know some
people who have the background in in
having studied stoicism can say aha
here's a stoic idea here's a stoic idea
here's one but if you don't have that
background if you haven't been reading a
good bit of Seneca consistently and I
don't think a lot of people in
philosophy are reading Seneca or or
Cicero or you know let alone Epictetus
you you might you know you might see
that and be like oh well that's a that's
a curious idea
um I guess she must have come up with it
herself or in the case of Batista he
must have come up with this himself
right yes but so you have to have and I
guess you know one of my one of my pet
peeves about people in the modern stoic
movement are those who say oh you know
it's just about practice I don't
actually have to read the stoic text I
can be a stoic without ever reading
Seneca or Epictetus or Aurelius or pick
whoever else you know we've got that you
wanted it to to bring up
um or I can just read some Snippets of
them and that that's enough you know
like a little peppering you know for the
for the dish the real dishes practice
and I'm always like Seneca himself says
you got to keep on reading you know and
actually restrict your information uh
consumption he doesn't use those terms
but you need to restrict the number of
books that you're reading so that you're
actually getting something that has some
real gripping power so if you don't do
that then when you encounter
stoicism in the wild let's call it right
the wild of a previously unread authors
things you're not going to recognize it
but if you have done the work then just
and you could say the same thing with
like epicureanism or you know uh not
just platonism not just in the sense of
Plato but middle platonism neoplatonism
if you haven't done if you haven't put
in the work you you don't get to
recognize the stuff when you see it any
more than like somebody who is going on
a hunting trip for the very first time
but never spends any time in the woods
they're not going to be able to like
look and see aha there's some pheasants
over there I just got to let the you
know dog run and flush them out and
they're going to be wandering around
kind of you know wide-eyed and and not
find anything
yeah well uh these are in a sense
humanists would read everything they
could get their hands on but in the time
of patriarch uh it's really astonishing
to consider this the average Monastery
library in Europe only had 60 books
and so yeah one of the great missions of
the humanists was to collect as many
manuscripts as possible and then like in
the 1440s they formed the first public
library in Florence and it started off
with about 600 books and then
uh Cosmo de Medici had 200 more copied
and he funded this whole thing and so
they ended up with this library with
like you know 800 books
but it was really just an astonishing
yeah time period but uh as far as uh
Patrick goes in terms of his own
stoicism he used exercises that he
learned from uh Seneca he did like the
Daily Review and he reviewed he regarded
like reading as a as a spiritual
practice as well and his own letters
that he wrote were based in part on
seneca's letters to lucilius and he's
one of uh Patrick's like most quoted
sources so he takes seneca's ideas and
then elaborates on them and uh I have to
tell you something that really shocked
me is that Patrick wrote several I mean
he just wrote letters to everyone so he
wrote some letters to the ghosts of his
favorite authors from the past and he
wrote one to Seneca as well and I was
like reading this and he he said senika
uh he started off and he said uh you
would not believe how much uh every day
I listened to your words and what that
literally means is that he was reading a
little bit of Seneca every day and so
that was a shack to someone like myself
who wrote a book called breakfast with
Seneca because the whole title comes
from this little ritual I developed of
reading like one or two of his letters
every day and so I thought wow this
person is a kindred spirit
interesting point I I like I like that
um observation uh kindred spirit so does
the reading and and not just reading but
reflection on and study of and perhaps
talking with each other about great
literature great great you know
literature that's conveying ideas and
making us grow as people
um you know we we started out talking
about uh the idea of like the
Renaissance itself and becoming a
greater more fully developed human being
and changing Society
um resuscitating a more abundant culture
so you know the natural thing to think
of is like reading groups or
um forums online where people can
discuss a particular author and bounce
ideas off of each other I realize this
is telescoping us way into the present
but I mean is that the model for
what we ought to be doing or that we can
work on ourselves but we also do we are
pro-social we we do need this connection
with other people and maybe there's
something lacking when we don't
we don't readily have Kindred Spirits
you know to right to support us to
reinforce the ideas that we're working
with right I think that's uh very
important and you can see that for
example like Patrick was really striving
for that but in some ways he was very
much a loner because he felt totally
disconnected from The Works in which he
lived and so he developed friendships
you know with these intellects from the
past which is something that Seneca
talks about but then he would share the
conversation with his correspondent so
he knew the most prominent intellectuals
in Europe and so he would write to them
and you know rehearse these ideas with
them and then later on in Florence when
the Renaissance started there would be
people who would get together and
basically have discussion groups and you
know like intellectual salons where they
would discuss things and there was this
really eccentric character
who was the biggest biblio file or book
collector say in Florence really
eccentric person Nicolo to Nicoli and he
had like 800 books that became uh the
basis of the first Library yeah
um but what he would do is he would
invite people over to his house and I
just love this idea and so he would
invite like young people over and he
would say take any book you know they're
like 800 manuscripts here take any book
read it for an hour and then after an
hour we're going to tell
each other about what we read and
discuss it
wow I mean that's a very interesting
design for a book group exercise right
yeah
if you did that with today's libraries
it would be cacophony
right because most of these most of
these things were written by ancient
authors so yeah uh one thing that's
really interesting about books is how
expensive they were because they were
all copied by hands so if you wanted to
commercially acquire a book and not copy
it yourself sometimes it would take like
a year to create like a nice book and
bind it
and the cost
actually would be the equivalent to what
an average person might make in a year
so you can extrapolate from that and say
that the cost of uh you know getting a
very nice quality book would be about
the cost of a car today really and yeah
yeah it's unbelievable it's a really
interesting comparison yeah and then
what happened in the late the late 1400s
is everything became much more
you know egalitarian so it wasn't just
like an elite that had access to books
because with the inventing with the
invention of the printing press say and
when books started to really become
printed
around 1470 uh for the cost of copying
two manuscripts by hand you could
actually produce 1 500 books wow so that
that was a technological Revolution for
sure yeah
I wanted to go back to something and I I
realized this is now leading us way back
into Antiquity
um one of the ideas that
I think you kind of invoked a little bit
that's coming from seneca's
um on the shortness of life is this
notion that as he says
the philosopher by studying other
people's philosophy gets to enjoy more
life and obviously it doesn't lengthen
your numerical years but it makes it in
some respects more intense and he talks
about being able to appropriate previous
ages to our own by anything that goes
through this wonderful you know typical
Seneca rhetoric you know uh uh you know
you do this with the Skeptics you do
this with the epicureans you do this
with a cynics you do you know and on and
on and on
um but I actually I'm very attracted to
that idea that by engaging with other
people's minds through their their works
that we
maybe create some space for them in
ourselves and we don't lose out on the
bargain it's not like we're containers
and we've only got you know like
Sherlock Holmes right you're probably
you probably remember the the very early
thing where Watson asks them how come
you don't know about all these important
things and he's like I only get so much
space in my brains and I need uh some of
it for you know the 77 different kinds
of tobacco there so I leave all the
philosophy and stuff like that to the
side somebody else can do that for me
um instead and then this kind of goes to
that notion of like expanding yourself
as a human being to become fully human
um Seneca is articulating this idea that
we we gain something
in the process of engaging with these
thinkers it's not as if they possess us
it's not as if they take away our
thoughts and replace them with their own
it's rather we become enriched by having
them as conversation partners
yes keeping them with us yes it's like
having colleagues from another age and
that yeah that's okay that's a good term
yeah yeah that became a very popular
idea in the Renaissance and there's a
famous quote from
Machiavelli about that about how alcohol
in the evening and change my clothes and
then I'll sit down with the ancient
authors and I will enter into their
minds and we'll have these conversations
together and things like that's really
beautiful lyrics I try that as a
practice
um my first teacher did was at Michigan
City teaching at Indiana State Prison
and you know it was full-time which was
great I had benefits and all that it was
about an hour commute so I would I drive
up and I and the days at the prison
were very long days so I'd be there and
they were good students you know a lot
of times they didn't have a great
academic background many of them had
gotten their geds in prison but they
were for the most part hungry and they
they wanted to to learn the stuff that
we had and they saw a real value in it
and to be fair there was already
um it was Maximum Security Prison so not
a lot of people moved in or moved out
and there were older guys who'd been
through the the four-year program that
we had and they would counsel the
younger guy so there was a culture of
Education in the cell blocks that was
reinforcing what what we did so I would
do my job you know and it was it was a
good job to have
um although you'd have to like shout
above fans and you know air conditioners
all the time and my I'd come home and my
vocal cords would be like you know you
know they were actually muscles because
they were worn out and I had a um a
study in our basement that had all these
bookshelves I'd framed it out and my
computer was down down there so I I you
know I would come home in my I I
generally wore like a jacket and tie or
a suit and tie because I wanted to
impress on these prisoners that what we
were doing was real education a lot of
the other people would give me a hard
time because they're wearing like polo
shirts or stuff like that
um so I'd come home and I'd go up to the
bedroom and I'd take off you know all my
my academic gear and then I would put on
like
um I you know I wasn't dressing down
right I was I was wearing some nice
clothes but they weren't the nice
clothes I would wear for work
and then I would go down into my study
and then I would get out Pascal or you
know uh Aristotle or you know uh
Epictetus or somebody like that and I
would sit in this this uh nice leather
chair that I'd inherited from my uncle
and have my you know at that time
usually a beer or a tea and just sit
there for an hour and try to do what
Machiavelli was talking about
deliberately and I found it it actually
worked out pretty good this this thing
about leaving one space and costume and
going deliberately into another
I won't say that like my reading
increased 110 or something like that
because I don't actually know but it
qualitatively it felt it felt different
you know yeah it's nice having those
little rituals like that or special
times or places that you have set aside
for different activities like yeah like
right now uh if I'm being a good person
I don't read Seneca when I wake up but I
study Italians
you know first thing in the morning when
my mind is fresh well one of the things
you write about in your book that I
think is a great example is
um every morning waking up with a cup of
black tea with milk in it and it you
know it's in the books I'm not I'm not
revealing any great secrets here your
wife brings it to you and if she doesn't
bring it to you know like you're in the
doghouse about something but she does
bring it to you most times and then you
you know you you sip your tea and that's
like the beginning of the day rather
than you know waking up hitting the
snooze button for the fourth time and
saying oh I gotta get to work
yeah and whenever I would get the tea I
would always think about how grateful I
was that's right different things yeah
yeah that's a good thing thinking about
gratitude when you wake up is actually a
very good practice of course
um Tim Ferriss is right in terms of life
hacks the the last thing you want to do
when you wake up is turn on your cell
phone that's you want to have some you
know free intellectual time in the
beginning space you're not exposed to
that yeah yeah
well back to to the Renaissance and and
stoicism
um I mean there's also all these
what would we call them eclectic
comparative figures who are
doing their own thing but they're also
saying hey the stoic said this the
Epicurean said this
um is that is that playing an important
role in the story because that's how it
often gets presented in the few
Renaissance philosophy textbooks that
are out there or not even textbooks but
histories of
Renaissance Philosophy from earlier
times
yeah well there was some eclecticism
because for example like
um
by the time you get later on then there
are more authors to read so people would
read the stoics as well as Plato yeah
and you know there were some very well
educated philosophers but usually
you know individuals who attempt to
gravitate towards you know when walking
in a school or another or another uh the
thing that is one of the things that's
really amazing about the Renaissance
which is really unique is that they were
able to accomplish all of these things
because they had this incredibly deep
sense of optimism about human nature
which I think we could use a dose of
today actually I think we've lost that
interesting yeah there's this one
scholar who said that the people in
Florence believe that they could
accomplish anything and because of that
belief they actually did
and there is some truth to that of
course they had you know very good
economic conditions which helped them
but there's this incredible sense of
optimism and there were all of these
breakthroughs as well and the
Renaissance it just wasn't a movement to
recover the knowledge of the past they
wanted to recover all the knowledge of
the past and then apply it in the
present day to create a better world and
also to create a better future and uh so
I think it's very interesting sort of
politically too because I think it shows
how our modern you know in our present
day culture we have this incredible
divide politically it's like you're
either conservative or Progressive you
know you have to be one or the other and
because everyone's worrying against
everyone and I think the Renaissance
shows that to be quite untrue because
this whole project of recovering the
knowledge of the past and preserving it
that's very conservative they want to
conserve you know the past and values
from the past but at the same time it
was like one of the most Innovative
periods in history and they wanted to
you know recover this knowledge from the
past but they wanted to even be able to
surpass it which they did
so yeah for example like Bruno leschi's
Dome on the Cathedral of Florence
um he it's a miracle that he constructed
it uh it's it's bigger than the domes of
the pantheon and the Hagia Sophia it's
made out of over four million bricks and
it's still the largest masonry dome in
the world and I think that first of all
you would have to be very optimistic to
undertake something like that because it
could have blown up and gone totally
wrong but I think that actually building
that
gave people an incredible amount of
optimism in Florence because it was it's
really equivalent for us today like you
know putting a man on the moon because
it was a technological achievement that
had never been attained in the past you
know and it would have to be not just
optimism on your part but you have to
have a supporting culture that would
yeah yeah we'll we'll contribute we'll
buy a brick you know uh this isn't a
foolish errand or something like that I
was wondering too uh as you're saying
that so
the Renaissance is there a sort of
General
take let's call it among the Renaissance
figures looking back at Antiquity
they're like yeah the the ideas that
they've they've got and maybe some of
the ways that they're approaching things
overall Viewpoint that was better in
Antiquity than it is in in the you know
the Dark Ages the time of scholasticism
but those ancients they didn't they
didn't apply this properly so that it's
it's sort of a tempered
looking back at
Antiquity they they didn't get all this
stuff right not in the sense of not
having the right ideas but
just not putting them into full practice
right
um like the republicanism idea you know
that everybody should be participating
and developing uh go ahead right that
that's a very good uh question because I
think it varied a little bit from people
for for example like Patrick in the
beginning he was sort of like very
backward looking in a sense and he maybe
felt that you know uh the literary works
from the past were like so great that
they could not be surpassed but then
when you get to like Leon Batista
Alberti he believed that there was like
a continual evolution in all of the Arts
and that we needed to study the past but
that it was possible actually to surpass
them
as well yeah but it seems to me that
really having that balance is important
because I I feel that we as a culture
have become
unmoored because we don't value the past
at all and
the whole idea of like progress and and
futurism in a lot of thinkers is based
on the idea of actually destroying the
past and I think that to be healthy yeah
psychologically and spiritually
as human beings that we need to feel
that we're part of History
yeah I mean you could say there's a lot
of deficient attitudes towards the past
um I mean I I one of the things that
I've seen happen over the course of my
lifetime is that
conservatives don't really conserve much
of anything anymore and I used to
actually when people would ask me are
you a conservative I'd say I'm too
traditional to be a conservative
um
um and and I've seen that sort of that's
kind of accelerated but there are like
this vast ecosystem of people who are
like yeah we need to be like the
Spartans man but they have no idea what
the Spartans were actually like you know
all this sort of
um you know Western Civilization is the
is the greatest and then they put some
images of things and you're like that's
uh that that's not even related to what
you're talking about and so there's a
weird kind of
let's call it
um adulation that takes out everything
that's you know most helpful from the
past and then there's the the past is
all crap it's all racist it's all sexist
it's all this or that you know uh very
pejorative attitude that you do see it
mostly on on the Progressive side
um and then I think another thing that's
the sort of a a deeper problem that both
of these perhaps are you know dwarfed by
is the
you know who was it that that said that
history is just one damn thing after
another was it was it Henry Ford or am I
am I attributing it to the wrong person
yeah that like none of this crap matters
yeah yeah I think sort of like the
modern view is sort of like what is
history sort of like a trendless
fluctuation yeah yeah and and all of
these are are sort of obstacles as
mindsets to having an appreciation and
obviously it's like not like any of us
are Galaxy brains where we could take in
all of the past and like appreciate all
of it we all have to kind of oh
specialize to some degree absolutely but
doing that there's there's a most cases
you find a deep richness that you can
uh participate within and bring back to
life and and has its own intrinsic
interest uh yeah yeah and then another
question is is what's left out right and
certainly it's true it's strange living
in the United States because nothing
there is very old so you don't have a
sense of the past and that's one of the
reasons I actually moved to Europe
because well I will tell you one thing
um this area uh used to be New France
and
um you know I my family is French
Canadian although we we've been in the
States since the Civil War and they just
kept bringing
um spouses down from Quebec and I got
wrapped up in that quebecois nationalism
back in especially around 95 when the
referendum was going to happen you know
and it was tied that was part of why I
studied French philosophy it was to
stick it to the anglos you know
um and uh it was it was it was so
ridiculous when I look back at it right
but they're you know you could say well
there was this like you know different
Paradigm different from what the English
were doing in you know New England in
the middle colonies and and and the
South
um they were you know different from
what the Spaniards were doing and their
colonial Empire
and you can do that but there's so few
gripping points that you don't have
enough there is history but you don't
have enough to have a robust Story I
mean we can't say like for example the
city I'm living in Milwaukee was founded
by the junos he was French Canadian she
was Menominee Indian and that's cool and
you can go to the museum and see like a
mock-up of them and and all of that sort
of stuff but it it doesn't go very very
deep you know yeah what I actually meant
by history is uh like a tangible
presence of the past like especially in
architecture so for example like here
where I live in Sarajevo
um you know there are buildings that are
500 years old like mosques from the
Ottoman Empire and there are buildings
from the austro-hungarian period that
are based on you know I think it's do
you think it's important to be able I
mean we've talked we've brought up
architecture a couple times and we can
talk in the Humanities about like you
know paintings and sculpture and all
these you know Wonderful works of art
that you go to a museum generally to see
or you look at online
but there's something to architecture
that's quite different I mean it uses
design principles and beauty is
ostensibly one of the values in it but
you can't walk through a painting the
way you can as you mentioned a mosque or
a Market Hall or pick whatever else it
is
is that not just tangible but
spatial
um you know being aware of uh the
construction materials around you not
just in front of you but you know the
periphery is that is there something
that that contributes That's Unique that
we need
well I think so because it does have it
has a huge impact on people and I think
they were actually conscious of this in
the Renaissance because they were trying
to recover like ancient architecture and
uh what all the Architects would do is I
mean this is an incredible tradition is
that much of the architecture in Rome
had been destroyed but all of the great
Architects would go to Rome and make
sketches of the buildings and measure
them and study their proportions so they
could replicate them and so they
recovered ancient architecture as well
and
um it seems that one of the reasons they
were trying to do this is actually to
create virtuous environments
in which to live and which could you
know Elevate the human mind as well how
does that work I mean when we think of
the virtues like let's say we just take
the four cardinal ones that platonism
and stoicism and others often use
how does being in say A you know
well-constructed beautiful building
how does that Foster things like justice
or courage or wisdom in our souls
well I I think the way that it works is
that
when you're in a beautifully designed
building that's built on good
proportions
uh there's like an underlying Gestalt
that you unconsciously perceive and
these are principles that were like used
in the creation of art as well yeah and
that it makes you feel
in harmony with the world in which you
live
because I could see it like promoting
Temperance then which is about
proportion and you know
um yeah yeah it's it's probably it's
more of a
um it's probably like more of a
Pythagorean a platonic
sense of the harmony of the world and
that you live in a cosmos which is a
beautiful order
and Pythagoras gave the name Cosmos to
the universe because of the harmonious
proportions so we see in nature I could
see how that could help Foster the
beginnings of Justice right which is
about realizing that other people matter
and you have to give them their due and
you know if you make up if you make an
events you follow through on them yeah
in uh for example like in Plato's view
Justice is actually a proportional
relationship itself where every part
receives its due and he's actually
appealing to those Pythagorean ideas of
Harmony and proportion which which
actually by definition give rise to
Beauty
so
uh and and part of it too uh I mean that
that's sort of like a deeper maybe like
aesthetic and maybe like a metaphysical
way of looking at at architecture but
part of this idea of virtuous
environments was just to
I mean the architecture can have a
profound effect on the human mind and
psyche and part of it was just to remind
people
you know that they were part of the past
yeah to elevate their thinking and you
know so so they would actually think of
themselves as being part of this you
know historical continuity
you know it's interesting so I teach at
Milwaukee Institute of Art and Design
where aesthetic you know concerns are
are very important and it's a small
institution so it's pretty agile it can
you know the leadership is accountable
to to
um the students and to the instructors
and staff and it's it's a pretty great
place to to work and they recently have
been doing renovations within the
building one there's four actually five
floors because they have a basement that
they call the river level and they
started with the fourth floor and you
know it was it was uh I think originally
a warehouse or a factory that they'd
bought and so you know it was all
concrete and and kind of uh
old-fashioned you know the the
classrooms were a little bit run down on
the fourth floor uh they did have an
adjunct office which was very nice and
they kept it stocked with like tea and
chocolates and things like that for us
which is a rather unusual but so they
they did this massive renovation and I
actually think it's you know pretty
pretty decent looking there's a lot more
light the classrooms
fit and work better our office is quite
nice now
but the students really didn't like it
and really they're yeah and it was
interesting to see what their response
was they they weren't praising the old
building those who remembered it
um they said that it looked too
corporate
you know and and it does have
it's sort of a generic Motif to it that
you could see in a lot of contemporary
buildings it didn't strike me that way
but that became maybe it's something
that like one student said it and then
others were like yeah that sounds right
man and then they just kind of
replicated it but it's gone down now
um to even be held by incoming freshmen
who never saw the older building there's
just something about the current fourth
floor that they find
off-putting and and this is the fourth
floor has become the model for the other
floors as they're renovated as well well
you have to send me some photos of that
so I can see yeah it was like that would
be really interesting but it's
interesting um
actually if you read marcelio ficino who
was uh the foremost platonic philosopher
of the Renaissance uh he makes the point
that for example like the cardinal
virtues I mean of course everyone would
say that the cardinal virtues are
important yeah
um
and you find those in Plato as well but
he he seems to have formed uh this idea
of the true the good and the Beautiful
You know which are like platonic
Concepts right what he argues is that
actually truth beauty and goodness are
higher than
the cardinal virtues because the
cardinal virtues are just things that
relate to the Civic realm whereas truth
goodness and Beauty are cosmic
principles okay
that underlie like the deepest aspects
of reality that's quite interesting say
that each of the virtues is a modality
of goodness right yeah exactly yes yes I
suppose you would say they're beautiful
and and they exhibit a certain sort of
truth but to escalate truth up to yeah
or beauty right to that level right yeah
and and truth would be you know knowing
these things or having a true vision of
reality but for example I guess the
platonic idea would be that
um so obviously you want the virtues but
then if you actually knew what the
essence of goodness was
you would be virtuous by Nature right
it's sort of like something yeah
irrevocably drawn to it there wouldn't
be yeah you could still have free will
but of course your will would incline
this way because you're not you're not a
dummy right because if you knew what if
you knew what goodness was you would
always be virtuous right so it's sort of
like seneca's idea you know because they
had a tendency to like collapse the
virtues the Romans stoics did and so
what did Seneca say he said that if you
always act in an honorable way you'll be
virtuous because if you act honorably
you would you know incorporate the four
cardinal virtue I think it's a very
similar idea to that okay
yeah well one of the things that because
I don't want to uh keep us too long we
try to keep these around 90 minutes or
so
um one of the things that I brought up
with you before because you're going to
be teaching a course shortly that is in
a Place full of uh beautiful artworks
and Mark by architecture I asked you
this question I'd like to hear your
response to it again isn't there a risk
if we make things too aesthetically
pleasing that the students involved in
something are going to pay too much
attention to their environment and not
enough to what it is that we're supposed
to be
offering to them is that is there a
danger of that or well let's think about
that but let me say one other thing
first because uh one thing I wanted to
say is what can we learn from the
Renaissance today Yeah okay or how could
we you know create the same kind of
cultural transformation and I think the
key really is in this idea of the studio
humanitarus and that what we could do is
bring back the idea uh to the humanities
that you can use the humanities to
create better people with better
characters so that there could be like
character formation in
um
education once again and I think it's
possible to teach that even in very
secular environments because when you
look at like the cardinal virtues
um you know practical wisdom uh urge
self-control and Justice it doesn't
matter if you're like a religious person
or an atheist like Massimo paluchi
those those virtues me
you know they're based on common sense
you know only someone who is mentally
deranged would think that those were a
lot like things that weren't valuable in
terms of human nature so I think that
there's a way to revive this kind of
educational system and it's actually
taking place in the classical education
movement in the United States which
um we have some correspondence about
this as you know it's not exactly
perfect I mean the idea is really great
I think that there's such a demand for
it now that they're having trouble
finding you know good teachers yeah uh
sometimes but
um it's possible to present these ideas
in a way that would really benefit
people students and Society I think in
in a non-ideological way because for
example you couldn't like go into a high
school or college and really teach a
course you know how to be a stoic I mean
I wouldn't want to do that yeah but you
can expose people to these ideas of you
know like classical virtue ethics and
then you can let them you know you can
engage in dialogue and let them think
about them and you know experiment with
the ideas and you know the practices and
things like that
and let them arrive at their own you
know decision but I think that actually
it seems like there is a huge demand for
this now and I think that one of the
reasons people are yeah at least
unconsciously drawn to stoicism is that
there's been a real breakdown in terms
of like cultural values say like perhaps
due to um
you know like post-modernism and
you know that people's values have
become much more relativistic and I
think that for example like the idea of
the cardinal virtues unconsciously
appeals to people because those are
things that
you can you know place your faith in as
you know valuable you know individual
qualities and social qualities you know
regardless of you know whether you're a
religious person or not those are just
basic you know human qualities and I
think that we need to recover that in
education so I do find the classical
education
movement to be somewhat actually quite
inspiring because uh they can't keep up
with you know the enrollments like you
know there's like a charter school
system that has like 30 000 students and
you put like the curriculum of the
classical education school next to the
public school and of course if it's a
charter school and you can go to it
without having to pay extra tuition I
mean it just makes total sense to do it
you know I really like that emphasis on
the need for there being a practical
component if you if you want to have it
not be like indoctrination you want to
say you know here's some ideas see if
they apply to your life
it's one thing if you only give them
here's the ideas check it out it's a
whole other thing if you have any sort
of Engagement where you're like oh so
here's how you take this idea and
practice it this week you know and what
results what happened you know taking a
a more experiential or experimental
um attitude towards it which doesn't
just say oh just play around with ideas
you know you still have to have the
rigor there but
right there needs to be some doing
something you know yeah I think that's
true I think that's true and um you know
that was the kind of approach that I
took in my book on Seneca because
uh yeah I'm not telling people you
should think like a stoic you know but
I'm saying you know this is what Seneca
thought and uh there are reasons why
these ideas are incredibly valuable in
human life there are all these Arguments
for them and these are the arguments so
you know you can look at the arguments
if they make sense to you you might
consider them and they're all these you
know practices that go along with it
that you can try out and so one of my
projects when I was working on the book
is to try out all the story practices
and see what kind of impact they had and
you know I didn't have any bad
experiences they were all good you know
that would make for an interesting
supplementary book
you know something that's a little bit
more I mean your book is fairly
autobiographical you use yourself as an
example a good portion of the time but
saying okay because you you conclude the
book before the end notes with a whole
bunch of stoic practices that people can
try and so you know you've done those
practices uh what were you know three
observations for each of these I think
people would be quite interested in that
uh yeah
yeah I mean I did reflect on those kinds
of things you know in the book you know
like yeah what happens to you if you
contemplate the death you know the
inevitable death of a family member well
one of the first things that happens is
that it increases your sense of
gratitude that you're with them right
now
you know so there are all these
takeaways yeah you know from doing these
practices that I think are very valuable
yeah
well but
as we as we ramp up
um
are there any other points that you're
particularly Keen to bring up no that's
right conversation I just wanted to
mention the fact that I think this is
very interesting because look the modern
stoics they're saying well you know
stoicism is cool I can uh you know use
these things for myself but what could
we do in society and I think if if you
really wanted to use these ideas to
change or improve the world that
creating an educational system based on
virtue ethics you know and giving it you
know yeah yeah the kids would really be
the thing because then when they go on
to college too it's like they're
concerned with professional skills and
things like that but that's quite true
yeah my whenever I think about the
situation in the Renaissance like the
belief that
Society had become totally corrupt I
always think about like the politicians
today you know and it's like it reminds
me of our present world and uh they they
never the people in the Renaissance they
they never thought they could create a
Utopia that was never their goal but
they did strive to create the best
possible world and Florence itself is an
embodiment of that both politically and
in terms of the Physical City itself and
its beauty so so that's that's my
thought on how you know these stoic
ideas could really be applied today in a
in a larger social sense but the other
thing too is that you can't expect to
have immediate change because
it took about three decades after
petrarch
uh came up with the ideas that would
lead to the Renaissance for it to
actually you know be embodied in society
so there's a time delay you can't you
can't just like flip flip a switch and
change the world you know which is like
one of the really I think bad aspects of
like
you know very extreme Progressive
politics
that people think that you can just
change the world overnight and it
doesn't really work that way like these
people who um I would say that's like
even more broadly spread all the all the
tech Bros are like this changes
everything you know exactly yeah or
something like that yeah well some you
know sometimes it does right sometimes
it does right rather unpredictably you
know unpredictable look at Facebook
bringing out meta which is now closed up
oh this is gonna be you know and those
of us who had seen Second Life are like
well I don't know that this is really
that that different uh but but all of
these people to the tune of billions and
billions of dollars were very uh taken
by the idea you know and I think you're
right yeah any any sort of real lasting
change has in an ethical sense in an
ethical sense because if you want to
change society if you want to create a
more ethical society that doesn't happen
overnight that's that's why it takes
Generations really it takes generations
and that's why these people for example
who go into art museums and you know
pour ketchup on paintings or just
recently in the fountain of Rome they
released all this charcoal that's like a
protest against climate change you know
that's you know there's this whole
movement where they're like
trying to uh gain attention for climate
change and of course I think you should
think about climate change but the
effect of doing something like that is
um
it's very just going to alienate people
against your cause I mean it's it's very
destructive yeah
wow on that on that uh black note yeah
black note exactly we'll bring this to a
close-up thank you for a very
stimulating conversation I'm sure a lot
of people are going to benefit from it I
think I'm actually gonna I teach a intro
to Humanities class that I'll probably
uh use this as a resource for for my my
students great great because I can
always use other perspectives right that
what they tend to get is like I said
just a mishmash of stuff you know
because it was the course was put
together by a committee long ago so we
do we do actually do the Antiquity
though which is good you know yeah and
just
um you know in closing I'll mention that
I am teaching this course in Florence
uh in November and actually it should be
enough I'll put a link to that um to
your site where people can find out
about that yeah and um and there are a
lot of articles relating to all of the
things we talked about on living ideas
journals so if you Google living ideas
Journal you'll find that and there's a
link to the course there as well so
excellent well you have a great rest of
the day and I'm going to get on with my
morning now but it's been wonderful
chatting yeah you're the most productive
person in the world
that's the facade
this has been really great speaking with
you and uh we'll definitely speak again
too because I want to talk to you about
some of your interests as well sounds
great okay super all right